[Music]
good evening everybody i'm jesse weber
and welcome to prime crime tonight
this is where we do a deeper dive into
the most high profile
and memorable true crime cases tonight a
killer
unlike any other june 7
2016 hobart wisconsin this midwest
village may not be a place that usually
comes to mind
but on that spring day hobart was to be
the scene
of a gruesome double murder that caught
headlines
this is a real life horror movie
description joel kennedy had been living
with his girlfriend sabrina teague and
her mother he son
sunny teague one day he and sabrina walk
into the home
hear the shower running and find stains
on the bathroom floor
suddenly a knife-wielding assailant
jumps out of the laundry room and
attacks them
he walked up and went to stab me and
then i put my arm up
and the blade went through my arm and
into my chest
while kennedy was able to hit the
attacker in the face with a shovel
and escape to call 9-1-1 sabrina and
sunny
didn't make it out alive both stabbed to
death in cold blood
but this wasn't a case of a stranger
lurking in the dark
but rather someone the victims knew
you know
[Music]
[Applause]
jacob kayer was sabrina's ex-boyfriend
after police arrest care they want to
understand
what happened but cair seems confused
what does mr care first start to talk to
you about that happened
that evening of june 7 2016.
he said did i take a car and smash it
into somebody
while he claims he was angry at sabrina
he's alleging that she blackmailed
his family and was making up a rape
allegation against him
in a tent makes a strange comment about
sunny
says that sonny's a real nice lady and
then what did mr care say next
i said it's unfortunate how things
turned out and even explains portions of
the incident
he said he attacked her the story
doesn't make sense
during cair's incredible trial the
prosecution put forward a
strong case that he intentionally killed
two people
and attempted to kill a third especially
by calling the surviving victim
joel kennedy to the stand he walked out
of the laundry room and
proceeded to attack us when you say he
who are you talking about
it was a trial that even saw the
defendant himself testify
and provide unforgettable moments about
what he says happened that day
and then after that there
um i'm i'm struggling with somebody
and this is in the kitchen of the
teachers and it's not
it's natural but in a move that trial
watchers are still debating and
scratching their heads over the jury
ultimately found that care committed
these crimes
but he was not legally responsible they
agreed with the defense's argument
that cair had a mental disease or defect
and couldn't appreciate the wrongfulness
of his actions what were your
conclusions
that first of all he has either
schizophrenia
or schizoaffective disorder
as his primary diagnoses instead of
going to prison
care was remanded to a mental health
institution
and here's the kicker under wisconsin
law
he could one day be released back into
the world
did the jury make the right call and
what was really going on
in jacob kayer's mind
let's start at the beginning with the
9-1 phone call and this is not from a
concerned citizen who's just peering
into the house
but what you are about to hear is the
surviving
victim of the attack joel kennedy
[Music]
not only a surviving victim but he is
identifying the attacker
in real time now listen to kennedy
explain
what happened to sabrina and sunny where
is the mail
i don't know
okay
[Music]
okay
all right let me bring in new york law
school professor kirk burkhalter
professor
kennedy would testify in this trial and
you know have a surviving victim like
him
i mean point the finger and say i saw
the killer that is a prosecutor's dream
yet the defense pointed to a number of
inconsistencies in his statements they
even suggested that he could be somehow
responsible
what do you think about his role here
it's very interesting
so i think that the inconsistencies
there were some minor inconsistencies in
this testimony
however the fact that he made the 9-1-1
call you had that smoking gun
tape so that is huge and that he is a
surviving victim he was injured
not to mention that it is not
unreasonable for someone
who is at the scene of a traumatic event
and as a matter of fact involved as a
victim
to have an inability to recall it 100
accurately
our memories are not video tapes we just
simply
press play but if certainly he was a
very powerful witness in this case
yeah and it's pretty amazing to think
about the fact that you have someone who
survived this how often can we say that
now police didn't have to go far to
apprehend care
he was in the woods behind the house
actually discovered
by the officer's dog
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
well after that take down kayer is
transported to the hospital now this
part is important
sergeant zachary holspot from the
sheriff's office says that cair
competently and voluntarily waived his
miranda rights
and he decided to talk to him how bad is
what kayer said to police well you
should think about it like this
his defense team tried desperately to
keep these statements out of court
but
[Music]
you know
[Music]
what's her you know a real name or any
other names for her or you just call her
sonny
she's um
yeah those aren't great comments of
somebody who suspected of murdering
these two people
the chao would describe that he was sick
of women treating him badly and how
sabrina was accusing him of rape which
all goes towards motive
he then described what he did
she would be doctors right away probably
[Music]
why would she need doctors right away
[Music]
so far as to draw a map for sergeant
hull spock of how the attack unfolded
not only that but kayer would
re-re-enact the stabbing as well
okay so like neck area upper shoulder
i always see your memories okay
[Music]
chest area or upper shoulder
area or close to the neck
okay i sat down with jacob cayer's
attorneys and i asked them
why did cayer say what he said to police
it's a little bit hard to get into
jacob's mind of course because of the
obvious mental health issues that he
deals with but i think that
jacob was probably in the throes of
whatever psychotic condition
led to this event and that's why i
thought you saw a lot of the statements
that you saw at the hospital
professor professor over to you we're
trying to understand if chaor confessed
and now his words came back to haunt him
or was he really not in his right mind
and maybe it was a mistake to interview
him at that point what do you think
well it's really interesting because
someone can be in the throes of some
type of psychotic break they certainly
could be
not in their right state of mind and
still
make confusion voluntarily and knowingly
which is the standard
and it appeared he appeared fairly lucid
here he knew
what he was saying he wasn't being
forced to say so he wasn't being coerced
made that full statement to the nurse
also so i understand what his defense is
saying but
um it seemed pretty clear here that this
was a
good confession
and the idea that you know he didn't run
away he was found behind the house
does that let you think that maybe he
didn't know what he was doing was wrong
interesting point quite possibly what
does one do
when they commit a crime normally one
would elude
capture try to get as far away from the
scene try to do something even if they
don't have a plan
but he remained at the crime scene and
that does
tend to lead one to believe that perhaps
he did not know uh what he was doing
uh the quality of his actions or that
they were wrong certainly
that factor uh would have helped the
defense
yeah i mean we're trying to figure out
what is going on in his mind and what
was he thinking and
it's not an easy place to be but i'll
tell you what when we come back
we're going to get into what jacob kayer
said in front of the jury
and what he said in front of the judge
we'll be back
[Music]
ask you some questions i think you even
wanted to see i think you were asking on
direct you wanted to be able to see the
backpacks been
maybe i can remember everything's in it
sure if you're gonna do that let me name
off every item
let's look at some no no no no no let's
just name everything
at least they have everything all right
well we'll show it and then i get to ask
the question
okay okay
sorry man i just don't like it i know
when jacob k or goes to trial for the
murders of his ex-girlfriend sabrina
teague and her mother
sonny he decides to take the stand now
he says in the day of the killings he
got into a disagreement with his family
he left the house but he was also
concerned that he was in danger
for seemingly getting into a beef with
this guy named dylan so he wants to make
sure
he doesn't leave empty-handed
when you left your parents house did you
take anything with you
yeah i chose one of my backpacks i have
like once
anything the camping show like you
need any type of scenario this is this
is your backpack that one's closed the
other one was food
and um uh then there's also some like
as you can you all saw like a certain
weapon tree for self protection because
like i said i am being attacked by
individuals
with guns and knives because i called
dylan gray i
i hacked his stuff actually i put it out
there hey this is you putting people on
heroin and that caused that
that's for protection so you so that was
some of the stuff you had in your back
items for protection
yes some of the things that look
concerning to to all you
those concerning things those things to
protect himself zip ties duct tape rope
gloves knives all of that was found in
his backpack
when he was apprehended by police behind
sabrina's home
speaking of which how do you end up
there
so how did you get this to sabrina
teagues i i couldn't tell you
other than other than that other than
once i viewed through my discovery that
i you find that the people that were
dylan's friends who have been up trying
to assault me attack me for a long time
did it get me did bring me there you can
see stuff like that and i was like okay
let's
go to what happened next something
happened at sabrina's
what happened at sabrina's
are you asking from like the memory
portion or
i'm asking for you to testify what's uh
about i know absolutely jack crabb if
you're asking from that point on
i have no memory as far as
later i had memory and then more memory
after i went to the jail
no memory of what happened surely he has
to remember
something after all he told police about
an attack and him fighting
i'm knocked out of my office i don't
have any more recollection of that
up until there's a part where i'm in a
vehicle
laying down and there's someone just by
my like
it's not really even holding me down
just they're just whatever whatever
and there's either rain or snare drum
type of sound
i got nothing for you out other than
that and then after that
there is um i'm i'm struggling with
somebody
and this is in the kitchen of the
teachers and it's not too
it's natural there's a i have a small
visual
what i'm being told in my description
was
adam i don't remember last night right
now as i wrote it down
holding me down
keyer would say that when he woke up in
the hospital he didn't remember
anything and he was very confused but we
actually have video of him
in the hospital watch
what the fuck
oh my god what the hell
what happened yeah what happened
you fucking told me i don't know you
tell us
hey what's your name what's your name so
we can help you lead the fifth get out
of there
we just want to know what your name is
we can help you
he would even say to nurses did i do
something stupid
professor there seems to be some
evidence that he might have gaps in his
memory
but at the same time what he does
remember is fighting with someone and
even suggests when he takes the stand
that he may have been framed
for the murders what are your thoughts
on this alternate theory
well certainly there appears to be gaps
in his memory no two ways about it
however he was going back to our
original point he was able to
draw a detailed map describing how he
committed this crime
and he was able to uh able to describe
to the police in great detail how he
committed the crime
frame for the murder i find that very
hard to believe uh you know he had the
instrumentalities
uh of a that that tended to show he
intended to commit a crime and he was
apprehended near the scene
now rather than being framed the issue
is whether he
is criminally responsible because all
the evidence tends to point that he too
the fact that he was the person
not to forget not to uh forget that the
victim one of the victims pointed him
out and identified him
yeah and that's a big point now i'll
tell you what you know who wasn't buying
this story
the prosecution and when they pushed him
on how convenient it was he just didn't
remember what happened
he pushed back yeah you're trying really
hard by the way
it's kind of funny oh i'm trying
you guys are trying really hard yeah
especially when everyone sees all the
statements you guys try to make and shit
okay well let's just get through this um
yeah i'll i'll try hard you try hard and
we'll get done with it
you guys have pissed me off early so
okay
i'm sorry specifically okay sorry about
that
i'm gonna just ask you a couple more
questions um
so when sergeant yankee said
so you're pushing forward the knife and
you say yes no i don't
i ignore her i ignore what she says she
won't play it again
she's like oh so you feel it going and
i'm like i completely ignore that
so i see you know what keep doing the
motion of what i'm seeing
i'm sorry i'm so fucking pissed it's
fucking me up right now i'll play it
again if you want if you don't believe
me
it's fine all right yeah because you
know what i'm talking about
okay look i got to tell you k are
testifying was something
many of us have never seen before and
when i spoke with his attorneys they
said look it was his
chance to tell his story that he always
planned to testify but at the end of the
day
how do they think he did i think
he did well i think that he could have
handled it
much differently both ways he could have
been a little bit more calm he could
have been a little bit more collected
but at the same time
he could have been a lot more
aggressive he could have said uh a lot a
lot uh
a lot more things uh in ways that uh
were a lot more a lot less pleasant
rather
the jury ended up convicting k of
murdering sabrina and sunny but when the
trial moved into phase two to determine
if he was not guilty due to a mental
disorder
cair didn't want to come to court in
fact he had a nice message
watch i don't want to be present
i do not like you people and i'm going
to give everything to the newsletter so
fuck y'all okay well he just
in addition to his kind words he just
flipped us off as well
yeah well i'll tell you what the jury
found chaor not
criminally responsible for the killings
because of his psychotic condition and
he was sent to a mental health facility
but he can legally petition for early
release
and be back in the world what does
attorneys have to say about this
realistically there's there isn't a
judge in the planet who would entertain
um in my opinion any release anytime
soon for somebody who has
the the profound level of mental illness
that really exists here
yes he can petition we don't have a
current plan to do so and frankly that's
a decision that would be made by the
treating
physicians at the mental hospital those
individuals can give us a good sense of
jacob's progress his receptiveness to
treatment
how he responds to that and once once
he's
completed a substantial portion of that
process however many years or decades
that might be
then at that point we would cross that
bridge
okay professor i want to get your
perspective on this could care
be released if not tomorrow if not the
next day
a few years from now is this a realistic
possibility
no i don't think so theoretically he
could be released but i don't see
him being released and why is that so
in order for him to be released he would
have to not pose
a threat to society at that particular
time
so in other words if it's five years
from now a doctor or physician
psychiatrist would have to determine he
doesn't pose a threat but there are two
things going against him
one he does clearly suffer from some
type of
severe emotional distress or mental
illness and two
he has clearly demonstrated the ability
to wear a fall
yep and the intention to commit a double
homicide
you cannot unring that bell and i don't
think any position
at the end of the day at the end of the
day we're dealing with a situation where
a man
commits double murder and may one day
get out
all thing the only thing i know is that
this is a case we're going to be talking
about for a while
well that's all we have for you on prime
crime tonight thank you for joining us
and until next time
be safe out there
you